il s'attendait à une triangulaire ce
sera un cavalier seul
henri vallès maire sortant de la charité
sur loire était passé à une trentaine de
voix d'une réélection au premier tour
après la défection des deux listes de
ses opposants il est assuré d'un second
mandat
ça a été a on peut pas le cacher une
certaine joual immédiate parce que bon
ça veut dire une sélection automatique
mais en même temps une certaine
frustration que j'espérais pouvoir
démontrer j'espère avec plus de votants
mais ce qui est pas sûr non plus ne fait
que jette je restais avec mon équipe
majoritaire sur la veille au soir du 15
mars pourtant tous les scénarios sont
encore possibles
la liste divers droite menée par jacky
tournefeuille et recueille 38,1 % la
liste citoyenne issu du mouvement des
gilet jaune 14 5% mais le confinement
attise les tensions à l'intérieur de
chaque équipe divergences de stratégie
fracture naissante entre les têtes de
liste et leurs troupes lorsque le second
tour est officialisé la rupture est acté
trente quatre colistiers des deux
groupes souhaite démissionner je crois
que c'est l'attitude des têtes de liste
que ce soit de notre côté que ce soit du
côté de l'autre liste et c'est le
changement d'orientation le changement
de stratégie souhaitée par les têtes de
liste qui voulait absolument gagner
devant l'impossible statu quo n'est le
projet d'une liste d'union après
discussion 27 noms sont trouvés mail
aventure se termine en préfecture
impossible de valider cette nouvelle
liste sans qu'elle ne soit déposée par
l'une des deux têtes de liste hors de
leur côté les anciens chefs de file
optent pour le sabordage et préfère ne
pas continuer
une douloureuse décision selon philippe
pavie officialisé sur les réseaux
sociaux pour ne pas dupe et les
habitants de la commune et une grande
frustration pour les colistiers
dissidents tout le monde a été déçu tout
le monde a été choqué ils ne sont pas
posé la question de savoir si les
charitois
allez comprendre on présente avec les
deux listes 53% des votes et ses 53 %
sont sont quelque part un peu voler le
28 juin les charitois devront donc voté
avec un seul bulletin à leur disposition
pour henri vallès il n'y aura pas de
suspense mais il s'attend à devoir
convaincre
je pense que de toute façon la
légitimité on leur à pas à travers le
vote là donc il faudra qu on l'acquiert
à travers nos actions tout au long de
mandat parce qu'avoir 100% de chez pas
20 ou 30 % de votants ça n'aura pas de
signification forte et donc il faudra
construire cette légitimité
pendant six ans il n'y aura donc pas
d'opposition au conseil municipal avec
trois listes candidates au premier tour
ce qui n'était jamais arrivé à la
charité sur loire dans les années 2000
personne ne s'attendait à un tel
scénario